en 1936 car racer et aux est joyeux ont
un fils qu'il prénomme claude en 1956
c'est à dire 20 ans plus tard le petit
brasseur le fils de brasseurs fait son
premier film et en 1986 cinquante ans
plus tard c'est la gitane de philippe de
broca alors de césar en dakar le petit
brasseur est devenu claude brasseur et
puis maintenant brasseur tout court
alors voici brasseur
bonjour brasseur thierry alors il ya des
brasseurs à la fiche depuis 1820 exact
et je m'excuse d'ailleurs mais c'est
comme ça alors quid de la prochaine
génération
est-ce qu alexandre brasseur va devenir
brasseur lui aussi or il l'est déjà et
lamballe attention maintenant il veut
faire il veut faire du cinéma et du
théâtre
ce que je souhaite avant tout c'est
qu'il ait envie d'être acteurs parce que
très souvent les mots comme ça on a un
aperçu un petit peu superficielle du
métier et ont envie d'être vedettes ils
ont envie d'être star ac avant tout il
faut avoir envie d'être acteurs et puis
après c'est le hasard la chance qui fait
le reste et votre père vous voulez vous
soyez acteur ou non on père m'a toujours
laissé libre ma mère souhaitait que je
sois architecte à d'accord j'ai fait je
fais quelques jets de bombes et offre au
projet j'ai laissé tomber archi et mais
je comprends très bien leur situation
enfin de tous les deux m'ont laissé
libre mais en même temps il avait envie
de me laisser libre mais c'est vrai que
quand on est dans une situation comme
était la leur aile comme est la mienne
vis à vis de mon fils on peut on peut
avoir des doutes est ce que c'est pas
parce que ça me paraît être une solution
de facilité à être acteur mais faut être
bon ah oui ça d'abord tout simplement
déjà avoir déjà en avoir envie parce que
il ya quand même pas mal d'acteurs et
puis c'est important c'est de travailler
je sais que si je n'étais pas vedette
je serais très heureux de pouvoir
exercer mon métier
n'importe où dans des théâtres de la
périphérie aussi alors professeur vous
nous sortez un bis que je m'en fais les
caméras s'appelle chasseurs de rêves un
peu plus particulier sur un peu
particulier alors on va en parler est ce
que vous croyez pas cac après ce qui
s'est passé sur le sur le dakar c'est un
peu bizarre de sortir un disque qu'on
appelle finalement la chanson du dakar
j'ai pas la chanson du dakar et puis je
tiens à préciser puisque vous me donnez
l'occasion que le disque a été
enregistré
bien avant et pour des raisons
particulières quand je dis bien avancé
non seulement bien avant l'accident mais
bien avant le rallye lui même puisque
j'ai fait ça dans le courant du mois de
décembre
un producteur est venue un jour me
me demander si je voulais participer un
enregistrement dont les ventes seraient
au bénéfice d'un groupe de médecins qui
travaillent sous le nom de l'ambassade
et ce groupe de médecins se met au
service des différentes manifestations
manifestations sportives comme le dakar
de cette année comme le rallye des
pharaons comme d'autres rallyes d'autres
petites manifestations sportives
municipales se met également au service
de manifester de manifestations
artistiques comme des concerts de rock
et la vente et les droits de ce disque
seront au bénéfice de cette société mais
je suis content que vous m'ayez poser la
question est-ce que c'est pas du tout
quelque chose c'est pas dans un esprit
mercantile et non pas là bien que vous
la preuve et c'est pas du tout pour
courir après un événement très bien
l'organe vos projets dont on n'entend
plus parler mais c'est vrai que vous
faites beaucoup d'autres choses
c'est cette pièce de théâtre écrite par
schaeffer qui a écrit amadeus et où vous
incarnerez y est bizarre et ce serait la
fin de l'empiré inca mis en scène par
polanski enfants rêvent tous de vous
voir là dedans mais c'est pour quand le
brasseur
bon on n'en parle pas parce que je
n'aime pas parler des choses quand elles
ne sont pas d'actualité
je crois pouvoir dire qu'on va commencer
à répéter cette pièce à la fin de la fin
de l'année et que là on entendra parler
puisque je pense qu'on va commencer à
jouer en environs du mois d'octobre
après d'accord mais voilà une
information merci